yeah well i mean you know
uh the the only friend i i friend i did
have
you know uh turned out to do some really
[ __ ] up [ __ ] oh yeah
oh wow should i just tell the story i
mean i've mentioned it i mean i got it
yeah
so [ __ ] it um so when i first started
making
black butler content which if you don't
know what black butler is it's a
a victorian era anime about a servant
and a
93 the anime it's very targeted towards
you know a female audience and um when i
started doing it i would do the voice of
sebastian so
i supposed to be able to foster i would
i would do prank calls you know and i
would call people up and i would tell
them oh my goodness my refrigerator's
running blah blah blah
there's a group of people watching this
right now who are just like falling from
the nostalgia
so i would do a lot of sebastian content
right and so in the show
there's a sebastian and there's a ciel
right so i thought to myself i need to
find someone who sounds exactly
like this guy because i sound exactly
like this guy yeah yeah and i found a
person
uh who who insisted on being called ciel
that's how into this character they were
right right right right and
i'm at the time you know they had a big
following and we were known together
and everyone just thought we were like
best mates but like i was sure they were
really [ __ ] weird
because first of all i used to just do
the sebastian thing the moment the
camera turned off i was like
i'm gonna go and play games uh i'm done
pretending to be a british guy
i'm a british guy yeah yeah i'm
pretending to be a butler but for them
it was like
they were living they never turned off
the persona right yeah yeah yeah
you couldn't like not call them that
because they would be like what the [ __ ]
i'm called
ciel and bear in mind this person's like
i don't know they were like 26 27 like
they
you know they should have it was weird
right yeah the 27 year old should not be
like
living with their parent only you know
i'm not dave i'm cl
right so you know it was weird
and one time they came to london and
then we hung out and it was really
really really weird oh you met him in
person i met him once in person because
i kind of felt like they'd help me out
because we did a lot of black butler
content but
then they started being really shitty
and they used to like flake on me and
then yeah
okay also also one thing they did that
was really sus is that you when we
collab together you don't ask for money
for me we're not labeling we both had
youtube channels yeah when they were on
my channel
they would ask me to pay them what and i
used to be like that's not how youtube
works
it's a mutual interest yeah but you know
they were like no we want to get paid
because my videos are doing better right
well that means that your channel will
get a huge doesn't matter so that was
also really frustrating to me
so i met them once in person after about
a year and a half and not speaking to
them because they were like i'm in
london
i lived in london they were like want to
hang out i was like fine we'll meet up
for
afternoon tea as you do afternoon tea
and then like
these these like americans filthy
americans
there was so they turned up and there
was like two other people there
who looked very very young like okay
like i asked one of them i was like how
old are you because they it was really
weird as well because they were like
attached
to them right i thought that's really
weird like they wouldn't they would take
it in turns holding on to the person
right right i thought wow that's really
sus i just thought okay this is you know
americans do american things
because as a british person right how i
i don't understand
things that americans do that are weird
or [ __ ] up right like because
americans are just quirky right so
americans just do their own things
we we all have like our own con like
stories about
right right people are doing weird
things that one weird american yeah
you know i i remember asking one of
these kids i was like how old are you
and they were like
18. and i don't think i'm like i had you
don't look 18. you look like 16.
is your parent okay with you coming here
alone and they were like yeah it's okay
i was like all right whatever i was
really weird i went home
i never spoke to them again because i
was really creeped out i left early
because i made an excuse that i had to
go
yeah it was just weird yeah there was
just like kids basically with him yeah i
was like i didn't sign up for this
yeah i thought we were gonna have an
awkward conversation for like two hours
alone and then i'd go
out like i thought that was what it was
you know and then uh
two three months later it must have been
it wasn't no no no it was like
eight months later right i get a dm on
discord of hey you should see this and
it was a
link to a local police report and i
thought what the [ __ ]
right so i click on it and it's like two
two counts of uh
molestation and one count of felony
molestation
i think oh no aggravated station which i
think is under 14 years old
yeah um now yeah and the
they were uh a person who identified as
a male but they were born
female so i think that's why a lot of
people just never thought that they
would do something yeah
right but yeah i i can't remember what
happened to them i don't want to keep up
with it like i don't
yeah i mean i'm i'm it's a mess i mean i
guess your hunch was
correct and that's yeah yeah and it's
one of those things where it's like [ __ ]
man like i
collab with this person like a lot like
yeah i think i i
the moment i found out that they were
being charged with all this stuff you
know even if you know
you want innocent until proven guilty
right yeah
i just didn't sit right with me yeah
leaving that stuff up i was like
even if it's a chance i don't want to
leave it up so i took all the videos
down which is like 40 or 50.
if you go to my social blade you'll see
like
views views minus nine million views
views views and there's i took them down
yeah i still got comments being like
where are the videos you know and i'm
like i don't want to
i want to break this bubble here you
know but yeah i mean i guess
yeah you have the thing now and it was
just like
oh god it was terrible and and and you
think back you're like [ __ ]
like why why why did you have to do that
yeah
what's wrong with you and then i felt
really guilty for ages because i was
like
[ __ ] did i help them did i help them
like first like did i facilitate this by
giving them more of a platform like yeah
it was just [ __ ] up and like everyone
i knew who was close to him
also was really weird and it was just
like it was a thing of like
just record this one thing then please
leave me alone yeah all the time before
because they were so weird
and i should have listened to my gut i
don't know why i did and i remember
it you always have that first kind of
experience where
you know meeting people on the internet
might not be the best idea sometimes or
people
some people are just really weird on the
internet you know are some people
you don't you don't always get that
until you actually hang out in real life
it's not like in a discord call